- [Interviewer] What do
you do for money now?
- Right now I'm sucking dick
and whatever it is I gotta do
to get whatever money I gotta
get and I'm really good at it,
so that's why, I mean, I don't turn down
those favor for favors, I do
what I gotta do to get money
and that's what I do and
I'm good at it, so fuck it.
- All right, Janet.
Janet, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in South Central.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family,
you had both parents growing up?
- I had my mom that was stay at home mom,
but she worked various
little jobs to get by.
My dad was in and out of the
house doing what he could
to make ends meet.
I stayed mostly with babysitters,
they had me laying in
bed with them sometimes
from time to time, they
would have certain females
that would come and have certain guys,
started to have some females
laying in the bed with me
as a baby, as a child.
I stayed there majority of
all the day, all the night,
eating beans and rice,
and that was pretty much it.
I, you know, stayed with them,
they always had me in the bed
while the other kids played in the street,
and it was just kinda awkward,
kinda weird, you know.
- [Interviewer] So,
sexual things going on.
- As a kid, I can't really recall,
but I'm pretty sure, because
we were in the bed, you know,
they would make me stay in the bed, so.
And those females would
basically pretty much
have certain females come over,
and make them lay in the bed with me,
and I just didn't get it as a child,
I didn't know, I didn't understand, so.
We stayed there majority
of, me and my brother,
my brother and my, my other
sister and brother stayed there
majority of the nights, my
mom worked various jobs,
so it was out and about doing whatever,
spending whatever money.
I didn't have any clothes growing up,
I had holes in my socks going to school.
I was always a hungry child,
always looking for food,
I don't know, I just never
really got what I wanted
as a child growing up, for Christmas.
It was just always a
deprived situation with me
all the time, so.
- [Interviewer] How were
your high school years?
- High school, I pretty much,
I worked from the age of
14 up until 25, which was.
Well not 25, around 22,
23, my mom passed away.
It was kind of awkward how found my mom.
One night I was out smoking
weed, I started smoking weed
and experimenting with
drugs when I was 21.
I came home one night after
hanging out with some friends,
and I went upstairs, went to
sleep, came back downstairs,
and I was just kinda
felt my way downstairs
to try to get some water,
something to drink,
I was so thirsty waking up
in the middle of the night,
and I I felt something on the floor,
and I'm like, "What is
this? What is this?"
And I turned the light
on and I was just shocked
out of my mind to find that it
was my mom dead on the floor,
and there was like no
explanation for it whatsoever.
So, I was like, "What the fuck,
"my mom is dead on the floor."
And they were like, my dad was in shock,
my brother was in shock, I was in shock
and I'm the one that found her.
And there was no explanation
for her being on the floor dead.
So, I'm screaming out
of my mind hysterically,
and, but I just, I felt
something wasn't right,
I just felt something wasn't right.
Shortly after my mom's birthday,
it was six seven days after that,
which was the 26th of March of 2005.
And it was just a horrible
day, it was a horrible day.
Shortly after the funeral,
my dad and my brother
and my sister took off
and they went to Vegas,
and I was stuck there at the
house that weekend by myself
with nothing, just feeling
alone, feeling depressed.
I wasn't really into smoking
cocaine around that time,
but I was experimenting every
now and again with crack,
but, you know, I didn't
really get into the meth habit
until I came out here to
LA, you know, by myself,
my my dad ended up getting
with some young girl,
18 years old, ended up getting
her pregnant shortly after,
it just was an awkward situation,
'cause at first me and her
got along, but then me and her
didn't get along.
He ended up kicking me out of the house
and putting out a
restraining order against me.
When he put a restraining
order out against me,
I ended up moving with a neighbor.
So, they ended up kicking me
out over a fight I got into
with the neighbor, and
I just kinda made my way
on a Greyhound out here
to LA, cause it's said
if Imma be homeless, I
might as well be out here,
I'd probably have more opportunities
as a homeless person out here.
- [Interviewer] Where were
you living at the time?
- I was living in Marina Valley.
- Okay.
- Riverside County,
out there in the IE.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own.
- I don't have any children at all,
so I'm blessed to have no kids right now,
and I'm homeless on the street,
living in a tent right now.
- Are you on skid row?
- I'm on skid row,
just kinda, you know.
- Are you using crystal meth?
- Using crystal meth,
that's basically my medication,
I use that all day every day
and there's nothing else I
wanna use but crystal meth,
because of the fact that I need to be able
to stay on a normal page,
which is I need to be able to function
if something is to go down
or something is to happen
on the streets, I gotta
be ready for whatever,
wherever life takes me, so,
and it's a lot of physical
abuse with men out here.
These men are abusive, they beat women up,
especially black women.
They like to fight black women,
they like to fuck black women up real bad
over any and every little thing out here.
So pretty much, I have
to stay on my P's and Q's
and I have to be able to defend myself
if I'm in a situation where
I'm not able to defend myself.
So, with that being said,
I smoke that every day,
and that's what keeps me
energetically up for the day.
You know, broken down more
than normal, you know,
and I have to be able to
function on a normal page,
with everybody else in society, so.
- What do you do for money now?
- Right now I'm sucking dick
and whatever it is I gotta do
to get whatever money I gotta get,
and I'm really good at it, so that's why,
I mean, I don't, I don't turn
down those favor for favors,
I do what I gotta do to get
money and that's what I do,
and I'm good at it, so fuck it.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have friends on the street?
- I have guy friends that I've
talked to that I can trust in
that I pretty much, you know, befriend
in case, you know, situations happen
where I have to have another guy step in,
and they have to basically
defend me in whatever situations.
I done had dudes on the
street that I was cool with,
that done beat the fuck
out of me over there,
right there in front of the Apple store,
right there on San Pedro.
I done had all types of shit happen to me
that just ain't been cool,
ain't been cool at all.
And it's embarrassing, you know,
when you get beat up by a dude.
When a dude hits you like
you're a fucking male,
or you're, you know what I mean?
Like they're taking you
all like they're men,
it's just really embarrassing
for the, you know,
the public to sit there and watch that,
and no one step in and no one help out,
and, you know, I done had
too many things happen
to where I just, I try to stay to myself
as much as I possibly can.
Sometimes days are slow,
where I don't have no money
and I have to, you know,
kick it with certain guys,
just kicking with certain
people and they'll bring me,
you know, they'll bring me
whatever crystal meth I need
to smoke for the day to keep me energized
for the day or whatever.
- [Interviewer] What's the
hardest part of your life?
- The hardest part of my
life is pretty much just,
not being able to have money
in my pocket pretty much.
You know, it just feels like
everything's falling down
when I don't have any money, I
feel like I have to basically
do whatever to get a meal or
whatever, I don't, I mean.
- [Interviewer] 'Cause your
back's against the wall
every day?
- Yeah, pretty much,
because it's like, I'd rather
have something in my pocket,
pretty much for the day, so I can, I feel,
like I have leverage.
Leverage in my life to be able to make
more decisions for myself,
I'm more open to do what I
want and have what I want,
and not have to sit there and settle.
So, I mean, me having money
in my pocket means a lot,
you know, being in this situation
but when I don't have it,
things are just, oh.
I have to basically take
things for what it is
and how they come, you know,
and I don't like having to live like that.
- [Interviewer] Are you
worried about diseases at all?
(indistinct)
- Pretty much,
diseases is something that, I mean,
if you nurture a disease,
it will eventually grow
and die out, you know.
You have to be able to know, you know,
go to school and have smarts
to be able to know how to balance
your chemical balance and what
you can tolerate in your body
and what you can't tolerate,
how I can get rid of this
disease, how I can do this,
what can I do to nurture this,
and if I take good care of
myself and I'm not putting myself
in the same predicament where
I'm active with the same guys
that are giving me certain things,
then I'm not gonna get
this disease anymore.
If I'm taking the right
medication that they're giving me
at these clinics, then it
shall die out, it shall pass.
You know what I'm saying, so
that's not really something
I really worry about a whole lot,
because I do use protection
and I'm not really sexually active.
I suck a lot of dick,
so I like sucking dick
and I'm good at it, so I pretty much,
that's what I pretty much do.
And, I mean, you know, I
make good money doing it,
you know, so.
- [Interviewer] What does
crystal meth do for you now?
- Crystal meth kinda just
gets me, gets me motivated.
Sometimes it gets me in the
mood, so that's another thing
that it does for me, not
just only does it keep me up
and on my toes every day and energized,
but it also gets me in a more
satisfying, relaxed mood,
to where I can kinda
chill, I can kick back,
I can be myself, I can feel more more
relaxed in situations and not.
But sometimes when I smoke too much of it,
I get real paranoid.
So, I get paranoid to where I'm always
looking over my shoulder
and that's not cool,
but I mean that's when
I smoke too much of it,
so I know how to balance it out
by smoking maybe a little
bit of weed with it, so.
- [Interviewer] What's been
the worst part of your life?
- The worst part of my life?
- [Interviewer] Then
roughest point of your life.
- The roughest point I would say,
just balancing my relationships
and trying to basically.
(exhaling loudly)
- [Interviewer] Historically
throughout your life,
when you were younger or now?
- The, just not having some stabability.
Stabability meaning not having
truce in certain situations
with any and everybody.
I deal with a lot, a lot on the streets,
so I deal with a lot of humiliation,
I deal with a lot of just
embarrassing situations,
and just a lot of negative talk,
and knowing how to get
over that negative talk
is one of the biggest
problems that I have,
because, in my past it's
always been something
that made me fall in situations.
On a real serious note, I
had to basically teach myself
some sort of guidance
and patience, you know.
I don't have a whole
lot of mentors or people
to kinda guide me, women
figures to kinda guide me
in the right direction, you know,
to give me that good advice and say,
"Hey, this is what you need
to be doing versus this."
You know, I don't really
have a whole lot of that
in my life, so that's basically
one of the biggest problems
I've always had to
basically self-teach myself
how to be more of an adult,
I had to learn how to be
an adult at a young age.
Now, I'm at an age where
I'm tryna kick back,
I'm tryna relax, I've
had jobs since I was 14,
I graduated high school on time
and held a full-time job at the same time.
So, that right there is
really hard all in itself.
I need to learn how to
teach myself how to relax
and not just be out there and, you know,
doing what everyone wants me to do.
Sometimes that is a big
problem, you know, for me,
is trying to just stay committed to myself
and learning patience and not giving into
what all these guys want all
the time because these guys,
they come and they want
this and they want that,
for this and this and that.
They want, always sexual, sexual, sexual,
and it's never a situation
where they're trying to
please me and the situation,
they just wanna get pleased all the time.
All the time, and it's
nothing you can really do
about it majority of the
time, because it's like,
you're basically getting what
they want or what they have,
you're gaining what they
have, you want what they have,
which is substance.
I wanna smoke, I wanna smoke crystal meth,
that's what I want, and
if I don't have no money,
then I have to come to you to get it.
Well, then they want their
sexual favor for this.
Hey, sometimes you got to do
it, or you got to give in,
even though it might not be what you want.
Other than that, you have to go get a job
if you don't have the
money to go pay for it,
you know what I'm saying, which is.
Majority of the time I
always have money for myself
to be able to pay for my own.
So, I don't really have to
really worry about that,
but there are times where I give in
because hey, it seems like
a good circumstance to say,
"Hey you'll let me into your apartment,
"I can go chill, I don't
have to worry about no cops
"and feeling paranoid, I can
come in smoke some crystal,
"and just kick back and not have to be
"looking over my shoulder," so.
- [Interviewer] Can you
envision a life where you're
off the street, living clean
to have a job, you're stable?
- Me going back to work is something that
probably I've been thinking about lately.
I've been thinking about getting a job
and going back to work.
I want a job that's gonna
pay me tips, I want something
that I'm gonna earn a
good amount of money.
Back when I was working,
minimum wage was about
eight something an hour, almost nine,
so now that I'm not working it's about
15 something dollars if not more.
I'm sure it's about $15
an hour, so, I mean,
that's a pretty big jump
from what it used to be,
so, I mean, for the most part,
I mean I can do that and
save money, and work,
and have something in my pocket,
but then when you work, here comes bills.
Here comes other
obligations and other bills
and unnecessarities that
I don't need right now.
Right now. I'm not saying
that, oh, the life for me
is me being in the streets
and just living in a tent
like I am now, that's not
the life that I wanna live
for myself, of course not, but right now,
I don't have any bills, I can save money.
I can save all the money, work a job,
save all the money that I accumulate,
whether it's selling dope or
whatever it is that I gotta do
to save money, so then I'll
have money in my pocket,
because if I have an apartment
I gotta pay light, rent,
cable, everything else that comes
with having an apartment,
you know what I'm saying?
So, and I won't be able to get GR,
I won't be able to get.
I will be able to get,
probably food stamps, maybe,
if I'm working part-time and I have a job,
but who's who's to know, who's to say,
you know what I'm saying, so.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think that's what attracts
a lot of people to this life down here
is just the lack of responsibility?
- You mean me having a job?
- [Interviewer] No, just people in general
that are living on the street.
- People that
are living on the street.
- You can stay down here
forever.
- People that live
on the street have a different mind state.
Their mind state is
basically saving money,
processing all types of
things that the public,
once I get into a public
community and I'm working,
in a working world, I will not have
the stipulations that I would have
if I was out here.
If I was out of here, I'm gaining
some sort of mental insight for myself,
which means that I am growing,
I'm changing mentally,
I am developing a way in a
pattern of life for myself
that will get me to a
higher goal for myself
that I can reach.
If I go out there and I go get a job,
I'm not really thinking
about my future a whole lot,
I'm thinking about what's
gonna help me make ends meet.
So, it'll be job for job, and job for job,
which can just end up, me
just working until a old age,
and not really having
those goals that I want.
I have a opportunity right now in my life
to be able to think about
what goals I want to get to.
What job do I actually wanna go get,
where, do I wanna actually
go back to school,
do I wanna graduate college,
do I want to further my education,
do I wanna take it to another extent,
do I wanna take up something
as far as artistry is concerned?
I wanna be a artist, do I
wanna be a music artist,
do I wanna be a painter,
do I wanna be a carpenter?
What is it that I wanna actually do?
So, I have time off
from actually being out
there in an apartment
where I have to, basically I'm
not able to think about that,
I'm working every day, eight hours a day.
I don't have a whole lot of time
to really take time to myself,
to think about what I want.
That's what I'm doing when I
go and I get a job right now,
versus me just being out
here and on the streets,
and actually sitting and thinking about
what my next move is gonna be.
So that's, it's like a whole
totally different side of life
that people don't really look at,
because they've always been taught
just to go to school after high school,
or get a job, or whatever
their parents wanted them to do
versus what they really
wanna do, you know.
- How old are you?
- I'm 37,
so I'm pretty old now (laughing).
But.
- You're still young,
you can still do anything you want.
- I feel like I'm old,
like if you count every calendar year,
I guess you could say
I'm 37 in calendar years,
but, I mean, I have a older mentality,
I'm very mature for my age,
I grew up at a young age like I said.
I had a lot of things happen to me
while I've been on the streets
since my mom has passed,
but it's given me time to really think
about what direction I wanna take my life.
Hey, so.
- All right Janet.
Well thank you so much for talking with me
and good luck with
whatever you choose to do.
- Thank you very much.
- Thanks.